tenemos una imagen y si se llama la
persona que ustedes
bien ahí era mi vecina
en el barrio popular
de santiago de cali en colombia
en esa época yo era apenas un estudiante
de medicina y los que son médicos aquí
saben que así estemos en primer semestre
los vecinos y familiares empiezan a
preguntarnos por diagnóstico y
tratamiento no no es tan primer semestre
y ya le están preguntando a uno que que
esto que es que tenemos y pues con jenny
no fue la excepción ella empezó a perder
peso al principio lo vio bien pues
digamos por el estereotipo pues de
belleza luego su mamá empezó a
preocuparse porque ya le empezó a notar
un poco más delgada era otra colombia
con muchos problemas de acceso a los
diagnósticos y seis meses después ya
estábamos interrogando un tema de una
posible
dificultad hepática llegó la primera
ecografía una masa nigga sugestivo le de
un cáncer de páncreas de esa época no
había cobertura diferencias en los
niveles de de cobertura de atención en
salud los vecinos la familia preocupada
por el tema nos dimos a la tarea pues de
hacer pasar fiestas para ayudar en el
tema de su tratamiento
desafortunadamente cuando recogimos
algún tipo de dinero y llegamos ya pues
para el tratamiento
desafortunadamente el diagnóstico
no lo fue
una masa muy grande inoperable y tiempo
después falleció digamos que este es un
tema que fue recurrente aún lo tenemos
en en colombia
el cáncer es un tema que nos toca a
todos todos los que estamos aquí de una
u otra manera tenemos relación con el
cáncer bien sea porque tienen un
paciente bien sea porque tienen un
familiar bien sea porque tiene un
compañero de trabajo bien sea porque son
pacientes de cáncer o en este momento lo
estemos incubando este no es un fenómeno
exclusivo de colombiano
de las batallas que hemos perdido aparte
del de las drogas la lucha con el tema
de la
del tema del cáncer las cifras en
términos generales no nos favorecen hoy
en día
los muertos por cáncer van en aumento en
el año 2015 tuvimos cerca de 9 millones
de muertos por cáncer en el mundo listo
en el año 2025 nosotros esperamos que
aproximadamente 12 millones de personas
fallezcan en el mundo y a ese año
nosotros tengamos
diagnóstico de más o menos unas 19
millones de personas o sea en el año
2025 esperamos 19 millones de personas
enfermas por cáncer
esto tiene múltiples explicaciones pues
sea para toda una mañana pero vamos a
referirnos a dos fenómenos que le atañen
a todo el mundo y que son importantes
para explicar parte de este fenómeno ya
ahorita
aquí alguien habló el tema de que
vivimos más ese es un tema que damos por
sentado y realmente ese es un fenómeno
nuevo ya a vivir más afortunadamente nos
tocó a nosotros cierto pero realmente
desde los años 50 si acá es que la
humanidad empieza por una serie de
mejorías en sus sistemas en avances
tecnológicos a que la gente viva más en
el caso japonés por ejemplo después de
la segunda guerra mundial en promedio un
japonés vivía 58 años un hombre japonés
vivía 58 años luego con toda la mejoría
del país pues al año 2020 se espera que
un japonés vivo en promedio 81 años eso
qué tiene que ver con el cáncer pues
básicamente que entre más vivimos mayor
probabilidad de enfermarse por un tipo
de esta patología ese es un tema cierto
el segundo fenómeno importante para
explicar este tipo de fenómeno es el
tema
de la urbanización osea pasamos de ser
comunidades rurales de vivir en zonas
dispersas a vivir concentrados y vivir
en las ciudades y alguien podrá decir
bueno y eso qué tiene que ver con el
tema de tener cáncer pues les digo que
mucho en una ciudad si usted vive en una
ciudad en donde todo lo tiene que hacer
en carro pues la única posibilidad de
caminar es pagando un gimnasio para ir a
a caminar y si no lo haces pues aparece
el sobrepeso con el sobrepeso la
obesidad y decirles pues que cuando
aparece la obesidad pues el cáncer tiene
ciertas predilecciones por ciertos tipos
de cáncer relacionados con la obesidad
segundo el tema de lo que respiramos
también si vives en una ciudad que todo
es quemando dice el por ejemplo pues eso
mismo respiras
depende de la ciudad donde vives así
mismo la posibilidad de respirar o no
sustancias que se relacionan con
enfermedades respiratorias y también con
cáncer pero vamos a ceñirnos al tema de
mi ciudad de cali colombia la segunda
causa de morir de las mujeres en cali es
el cáncer de cérvix antes se pensaba que
era un castigo divino luego después de
los 50 todos luchamos le echamos la
culpa a la genética les decíamos nuestro
genético es que si a su abuela le dio
cáncer de cérvix y a su mamá le dio
cáncer de cérvix pues a usted llevar
también cáncer de cérvix una caleña hizo
un gran aporte al mundo y fue el decirle
demostrarle al mundo que no es producto
de la genética sino un virus que
permanentemente está en la población
colombiana es una de las enfermedades de
transmisión sexual más frecuente
probablemente aquí en el auditorio si
hiciéramos un panel a virus de papiloma
humano el 70 por ciento en promedio
lo padecimos lo padecemos lo tenemos en
este momento y eso hace que las mujeres
se enfermen por virus del papiloma
humano y hay una relación de casi el 100
por ciento de las personas que padecen
cáncer de cérvix y lo mismo en cáncer de
garganta un 30 por ciento un 70 por
ciento en cáncer de vulva un 80 por
ciento en cáncer de ano un 50% en cáncer
de pene ya tiene explicación entonces
todo esto para decirles que dependiendo
de dónde vives y cómo vivimos pues
también la posibilidad de tener ciertos
tipos de cáncer como mencionaban ahora
el envejecimiento y el cáncer son dos
temas de preocupación en los países del
primer mundo pues se dieron a la tarea
de crear registros poblacionales que son
los registros poblacionales un sistema
metodológico en donde se lleva el
registro de cada paciente que se enferma
por cáncer de que se enferma qué
tratamiento recibió qué complicación
tuvo
y cuál fue el resultado esto en aras de
que pues para que su país
se entere dónde están las dificultades y
propongan mejores cali tiene un registro
poblacional comparable en el mundo de
más o menos 55 años oigan bien 55 años
nosotros los caleños lo hacen una de
nuestras universidades la universidad
del valle sabemos de que se ha enfermado
cada paciente con cáncer qué tratamiento
ha recibido qué complicación ha tenido y
cuál es su resultado entonces en este
escenario el mundo dice la comunidad
internacional dice bueno el cáncer va
subiendo que hacemos y no vemos y
entonces aparece la iniciativa de
ciudades que luchan contra el cáncer
ya la lucha no va a ser por regiones ni
por países no tienen que ser expedito
porque cada ciudad cada localidad
determina el tipo de cáncer que tienen
las ciudades entonces se sacó una
convocatoria a nivel mundial 200
ciudades participamos luego se escogen
100 se preseleccionarán 12 y finalmente
quedamos 3
anuncian en suiza en el marco del foro
monetario internacional cali asunción
paraguay
django me amar en birmania y en el
último congreso mundial acaban de
incorporar a kumasi en gana
cuál es el reto disminuir el 25 por
ciento de los muertos que tenemos en
cali al año 2025
es mucha gente nos dice nuestro stand
fuma 2
cierto porque pues eso es impensable
pero se van a dar cuenta que no estamos
dando
tan fuera de contexto
la unión internacional es un grupo de
socios mil socios donde están países
filántropos todas las casas
farmacéuticas que hacen
medicamentos contra el cáncer equipos
contra el cáncer y todas aquellas
personas que luchan contra el cáncer
están ahí para explicarles que las
ciudades como lo hacemos esto cómo se
come cómo se se digiere el tema es
primero se hace un diagnóstico de ciudad
listo el diagnóstico de ciudad lo que
dice es bueno que tiene esta ciudad para
luchar contra el cáncer entonces 180
especialistas en cali se sentaron a
dolores
a hacer el diagnóstico de ciudad en
recurso humano talento instituciones
capacidad de cualificar el recurso
humano cuidados paliativos y todo el
tendido social en cali y entonces este
diagnóstico se le presenta a los
expertos de la unión internacional los
expertos de ley de la organización
internacional dicen bueno si ustedes
están luchando contra esto con esto para
el cáncer en cali y tienen este tipo de
patologías ustedes lo que necesitan es
esto en un estado ideal cierto ese es
nuestro plan nos sentamos todos los que
estamos ahí ahí estamos todos en
colombia está el ministerio está el
instituto nacional de cáncer en el ims
está el departamento estamos nosotros la
fundación valle del lili imbanaco bueno
todos los que hacen cáncer en cali se
avala el plan y viene la fase de
implementación en esa fase
implementación pues no es otra cosa que
un cabildeo
entonces en medio de los socios buscamos
quién tiene lo que cali necesita cierto
y entonces vamos ubicando en términos de
recursos humanos necesitamos esto
tecnológicos esto y la gente ayudando en
ese en ese cometido
avances que tenemos de esa fase de
implementación lo primero es que la
presidenta de la unión internacional que
es el máximo ente asesor de la
organización mundial de la salud en la
princesa dina de jordania ya vino a cali
a presentar esta apuesta del mundo en
colombia y entonces ya nos reunimos con
las autoridades locales con todo el
notable hato del valle del cauca o sea
los que tienen la plata cierto y pues
eso es un tema como protocolario y uno
va detrás pues con la con la coca
recogiendo
después d
de este tema pues nosotros
ya pasamos a bueno y qué más sigue
entonces ya en cali uno de los otros no
somos un mar de problemas ya con el
trabajo técnico nos damos cuenta que
realmente tenemos 28 problemas
estratégicos 15 objetivos que alcanzar
uno de ellos es el tema de recurso
humano las sociedades de patología y
radiología en eeuu y en europa ya están
en cali entrenando patólogos y
radiólogos citotecnólogos porque uno de
los problemas identificados grandotes
que permean todo el tema de salud en
cali es la dificultad que tenemos con
los diagnósticos a veces no somos tan
tan finos y eso marca la diferencia
en la oportunidad para los pacientes y
esa primera parte ya se está haciendo la
segunda la cruzada que tenemos en
colombia para eliminar el virus del
papiloma humano afortunadamente el
anterior ministro alejandro gaviria pues
está en este tema muy sensible con el
cierto y nos garantizó las vacunas para
valga la redundancia vacunar todas las
niñas de 9 a 21 años en la ciudad de
santiago de cali lograr coberturas del
90 por ciento y eliminar el virus del
papiloma humano no ha sido fácil en un
foro me preguntaban bueno si ustedes son
un país de renta media cierto el tema de
la plata
y la verdad
con esos socios de los que le estoy
hablando la verdad la plata
no es si es importante pero pasa a un
segundo plano el problema más difícil de
la implementación del plan ha sido el
ponernos de acuerdo ha sido fácil ese
tema de de lidiar con los egos nefasto
ya o sea de verdad el anteponer cuando
uno tiene un propósito común el que la
gente se desprenda de su interés
personal de su interés institucional ha
sido lo más complicado
o sea la verdad ese ha sido como el tema
más difícil como pueden ver no estamos
tan formados cierto creemos que podemos
colombia tiene una oportunidad bonita de
hacer algo diferente con lo mismo que
tenemos siendo más eficientes mirando
cómo logramos sumar esfuerzos yo pienso
que de verdad no queremos contar más
historias como jenny cierto no queremos
más esas historias esta vez no nos
podemos dar el lujo de llegar tarde
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]